anny McCarthy is a contributing editor
at national review of former assistant
US attorney for the Southern District of
New York one of the most eloquent
writers on Law and Justice there is any
thanks very much for coming on
so assess these charges if you would as
someone who has brought charges within
the context of the broader investigation
do these charges bring us closer as
Americans to understanding how our
democracy was hacked in 2016 no I think
the takeaway tucker with with due
respect to mr. stone and this is
obviously immense importance to him to
the country it seems to me that this set
of charges underscores what seems to
have been obvious for over a year and
that is that there never was a
conspiracy between the Trump campaign
and the Kremlin to commit espionage it
seems to me that that is something
that's been obvious to investigators for
a very long time and this latest set of
charges indicates that they not only
were not in cahoots with Russia they
didn't actually know what
why key leaks had so as you pointed out
in your interview with stone there's no
charge in the indictment that stone
who's facing seven felony charges was in
any kind of a criminal conspiracy with
why key leaks all this is about is the
process of investigating the so-called
Trump Russia conspiracy which it seems
to me not only didn't exist but they've
long known that it didn't exist I'm
fixated on the CNN tape of this raid on
Stone's house this morning because I
think like a lot of people I looked at
that and I thought this is not at all
the country that I grew up in or want to
live in if a prosecutor says we go to
the house of a 66 year old man we know
doesn't have a passport or a gun who
lives with his older wife who's deaf and
their dogs and cats and we need 27 armed
federal agents each with a sidearm in an
ar-15 is there anybody who says you know
what that's just that's just wrong
that's overkill we don't need to do this
it's actually dangerous why are we doing
this
wouldn't anyone push back against that
idea yeah I don't know Tucker because
this is not the first time this has
happened in this investigation
when Paul Manafort when there was a raid
on his home in Virginia it was on the
night between two days when he was
cooperating with two different
congressional committees and it was
under circumstances where the special
counsels office knew his very well
respected lawyers in Washington and
could easily have called up the lawyer
and said here's a subpoena these are the
these are the items we want there was
certainly no reason to do it the way
they did it and here today what happened
here seems to me to be complete overkill
to take somebody who is at best what you
would think of as a white-collar
criminal if he's actually guilty of the
charges who's committed processed crimes
and treat him like he was a Mafia Don or
Osama bin Laden to me just seems to be
crazy and the proof is in the pudding if
you really think this guy is either a
danger to the agents who were conducting
the search or a risk of flight one thing
you don't do is agree to let him out on
his signature to a two hundred and fifty
thousand dollar bail bond I mean he
either is this evil guy or he's not it
kind of reveals the motive doesn't it
and and finally there's been a lot of
debate today about how a CNN producer
with a camera wound up at the scene at
five something in the morning CNN has an
explanation for it I don't know if it's
true or not is it plausible in your mind
that a prosecutor in this in this
investigation would tip off a news
organization I mean if you're gonna
conduct a raid like this presumably
you're doing it for shock and awe would
it be so strange to let a news
organization a sympathetic one no I
don't think it would be strange to do
that particularly under circumstances
where it looks like there was a lot of
orchestrating the media response here as
I understand it the raid began at six
o'clock the press release was issued at
six was at 6:17 I think Catherine
Herridge said yeah this morning so that
obviously is suspicious I'm
also aware of investigations where for
example the media finds out that you
know there's some leak in the
investigation the media finds out
there's going to be a raid and the
government makes a deal that they can be
on the scene as long as they don't leak
the fact of the raid so that people get
a chance to escape
so I until we know all the facts I
wouldn't jump to conclusions no I'm
nervous I'm not but what you're
describing is its own form of collusion
I would know if true Andy McCarthy thank
you very much collusions of us could
collusions very loose term there so
there's a loose term and it's a common
phenomenon here in Washington I can tell
you thank you very much